- You know what?
- Hey, you guys,
this is an inaccurate quiz.
- It's like this.
- Just a little.
(electronic music)
- Hey guys, it's the
cast of Descendants Two
and we are at Buzzfeed and
we're about to find out
which Disney princess we are.
- I'm very excited.
- Are we ready for this?
- I think.
- [Sofia] Alright, first question:
What is your favorite Disney movie?
- Black Cauldron
- I'm stuck between Freaky Friday and
Lady and the Tramp.
- I'm gonna go with Hunchback.
- You know what? The Lion King.
What am I even doing?
- Oh wait, Hunchback is a good one too.
Black Cauldron, though.
Next one is,
secretly, you think your
enemies are envious of?
I think I have to say I don't
have any enemies, right?
- That's what I said too.
- Yeah.
- My dreams, maybe.
I almost wanna pick that just because you
guys picked the other one.
- Do it.
- I'll do it.
- [China Anne] What
are you most scared of?
- I'm gonna go with war.
- War is pretty scary, right?
- [Sofia] Pretty scary.
Standing still, global warming, scissors.
- Scissors.
- I feel like it's either Walmart or war.
- Walmart is pretty scary.
- Well, I mean, war and global warming
are kind of the biggest threats, though.
Ima go with global warming.
- Okay, I respect you guys.
- What do you look for in a soul mate?
I would either be passion or
adventure or humor?
Okay, yeah, okay,
I'm gonna have to go with
a sense of adventure.
Choose a talking animal.
My favorite.
Favorite kind.
Shark
- Opossum
- I need a talking shark in my life.
One hundred percent.
- You know, I'm going with phoenix, man.
- I think I want a mouse,
I had one in Cinderella
Story, it was very cute.
- Anybody who chose Animals
Can't Talk have no soul.
- You always say I'm like Minnie Mouse
- [China Anne] What do you
like to do with your time off?
- I feel like get out of
town or I'm always working.
- Yeah, I'm either get
together with my family
or I'm always working.
- I'm out.
- Get out of town; I like
to go on random vacays.
- I'm gonna go with get
together with my family.
- Man, I love my family.
Yeah, I'm gonna go with that too.
- [Dove] What is the secret to true love?
Ooh, it's gotta be either
communication, compassion or humor.
- Is there an I don't know button.
- Yeah, I don't know.
I'll know when I find it.
- But I feel like humor comes
from a sense of like happiness
and joy and when you're on
the same page with that--
- Being comfortable with someone.
- Yeah, then it's like
everything's in alignment.
At least for me.
- I'll know when I find it.
- You can have chemistry with
someone that you do not love.
- True, I'll know when I find
it is what I'm gonna go with.
- [Dove] Where do you like
to have your first date?
- Sofia's always into club
- No, I'm not.
I'm like into club called bed.
- I know Sofia's like:
"I go to bed every night at nine"
Just kidding, she's at all the clubs.
Can you picture her on her own
just like bopping in the corner.
- With my little glasses
and sipping some tea.
You can find me in da club.
- You know what, it's the first date.
Da club.
- Where we going later tonight?
- To the club.
- For a first date, I feel like
the movie theater's perfect
'cause you don't have to
and or talk to that person.
- No, but then you don't
get to talk to them.
- She's like, you don't
have to look at them,
talk to them.
- Avoid all contact.
- You got snacks.
- I'm just saying, it's just like
if I can't sit and
comfortably sit next to you
and watch a movie
- But, then there's like that
awkward moment where like, do
you touch the person's hand?
- Well, Sofia when you and I
were going on out first date,
what did we do?
Da club.
- It was da club.
- I totally forgot.
- Should we all just pick da club?
You know what I don't have time to date,
that's final answer.
So, pick an artist.
- [Dove] I wanna listen to Bruno Mars.
- [China Anne] Drake.
- I really love Miley's music lately
but I love Bruno Mars.
- Bruno.
- [China Anne] Bruno?
- [Sofia] What is Happily Ever After?
That is the question.
- In finding inner peace,
for sure, one hundred.
Because when you do that
everything else falls into place, right?
- [China Anne] No, yeah,
I'm picking that too.
- We got our answers!
- Wait, I'm not done, I'm
not done, I'm not done!
- Okay well--
- What?!
- Wait, Rapunzel? Wait, I got Mulan.
- I got Ariel.
- I got Rapunzel.
I wanted to get Belle.
- I wanted to get Rapunzel.
Okay, now we're going to take
Which Disney Prince is our True Love,
you guys ready?
You got Aladdin?
- I got Aladdin too.
- Oh what, why did I get beast?
I got beast.
And he's not even like
the prince version of beast.
- He's the beast version of beast.
Are we about to
fight in the club?
- How do these work?
- No I'm gonna be the one
in the club with beast.
- Keeping up with Dove, China and Sofia
in da club.
- I hate you so much.